[Aplausos]
[Música]
y por una vez los pronósticos se
cumplieron el presidente de Francia
Emmanuel macrón no solo venció sino que
aplastó a su rival Mari lepen en la
segunda vuelta de las presidenciales
francesas hablamos Ni más ni menos que
de 16 puntos de diferencia
aproximadamente un 58% para macron y un
42% para LP Sí vale Hablamos de una
diferencia mucho más reducida que las
anteriores presidenciales Y las que
también se enfrentaron estos dos
políticos y en las que la distancia
entre ambos fue de 32 puntos pero qué
queréis que os diga aún así Hablamos de
una enorme diferencia en un país donde
la relación no es precisamente algo
común porque amigos la victoria de
macron supone la primera vez en 20 años
que un presidente francés ha conseguido
un segundo mandato y la primera en más
de 50 años que lo ha hecho dominando
completamente la vida política es decir
sin tener que contar con un gobierno y
un Primer Ministro de otro partido
distinto elegido por la asamblea
nacional la primera vez en más de 50
años
no me negaréis que se tratara de todo un
tanto político más aún si tenemos en
cuenta que la reelección Se ha producido
tras una pandemia una crisis y en medio
de una enorme espiral inflacionista y
que encima la abstención ha sido enorme
y a ver cuando quieres cambiar o
prefieres la alternativa Pues no te
quedas en casa En otras palabras casi
que podemos hablar de un nuevo rey sol
para la política francesa no es el líder
más querido y tiene fama de autoritario
pero tiene mando en plaza y sí lo más
chocante de todo es que los franceses no
le profesan especial cariño de hecho las
encuestas de valoración habitualmente se
le tacha de ser arrogante autoritario y
es no seguro que fotos como esta no
ayudan
y no solo eso tampoco podemos decir que
su propuesta política parezca encandilar
a las masas
en la primera vuelta casi el 60% de los
votantes franceses apoyaron a los
candidatos más escolados a la derecha o
a la izquierda de hecho su Victoria ha
venido acompañada de una abstención de
28 puntos la más alta también en medio
siglo en una segunda vuelta electoral
está claro amigos no levanta pasiones
Pero entonces por qué ha arrollado el
presidente galo Hacia dónde se dirige la
política francesa que podemos esperar de
este nuevo mandato al frente de la
France Pues bien veámoslo Por cierto
sabíais que el pentágono es el edificio
administrativo más grande del planeta os
gustaría conocer todos sus secretos pues
no olvides echarle un vistazo al vídeo
que hemos preparado en nuestro canal
hermano mega projects y además si os
gusta la economía no olvidéis echarle un
vistazo también al último miembro de la
familia al recién llegado visual
económico que por cierto ha sido todo un
éxito en menos de dos semanas hemos
pasado los 110.000 suscriptores estamos
alucinando y esto la verdad es que
gracias a todos vosotros Así que desde
aquí un millón de gracias os dejamos
todos los links por abajo la descripción
y dicho esto continuemos
[Música]
porque macron
el líder francés ha manejado Francia con
mano firme en 2017 llegó al poder que al
grito de ni de derechas ni de izquierdas
solo el mismo para intentar dar forma a
una nueva Francia Pues bien a lo largo
de su primer mandato hubo momentos en
los que su presidencia parecía acerca
del fin sin embargo siempre siempre se
repuso una y otra vez ahí tenemos por
ejemplo el caso de los chalecos
amarillos Las mayores protestas en
décadas o incluso la crisis de la Kobe
19 donde por ejemplo al comienzo de los
franceses se encontraban entre los más
escépticos con las vacunas hoy el 78% de
su población está completamente vacunada
un porcentaje superior al de Alemania el
Reino Unido los Estados Unidos pero
sobre todo macron ha intentado
modernizar el país galo y cuando
hablamos de modernizar Francia hablamos
sobre todo de su economía
porque para que os hagáis una idea la
economía de Francia ha crecido una media
del 1% Durante los últimos 10 años y si
en vez de mirar el conjunto de la
economía miramos el pib Per cápita bueno
creo que una imagen vale más que mil
palabras atentos a este gráfico
en dólares internacionales los franceses
llevan perdiendo riqueza desde hace más
de 14 años e incluso si eliminamos el
efecto de los tipos de cambio y las
variaciones de precio el resultado no es
mucho mejor la producción de la economía
francesa apenas incrementó un 6% en toda
la década anterior a la pandemia Este es
un registro mucho peor que el de la
mayor parte de los países desarrollados
es decir tal y como podéis ver la
economía francesa ha estado
prácticamente en coma si tuviéramos que
definir sus números durante la última
década siendo generosos podríamos decir
que son decepcionantes y eso siendo
generosos hablamos de un déficit de más
de 6% del pib una deuda pública superior
al 112 un gasto público desorbitado que
supone Ni más ni menos que más del 56%
de toda la economía y un crecimiento
prácticamente nulo en los últimos años
la verdad Hace es que resulta difícil
encontrar alguna estadística donde las
cosas se han ido relativamente bien De
hecho se me ocurre que un indicador
bueno puede ser la producción industrial
que en los países desarrollados se
encuentra en sus máximos históricos y
Francia ha sido tradicionalmente un
turismo Industrial Así que la pregunta
es cómo ha evolucionado la producción de
la industria francesa pues amigos de
nuevo creo que una imagen vale más que
mil palabras
Pues bien para solucionarlo macron ha
hecho esfuerzos por desregular la
economía y reducir los impuestos
esfuerzos que han sido muy bien acogidos
por la comunidad empresarial y que por
ejemplo han posibilitado que el
desempleo se reduzca hasta el 7%. el
nivel más bajo desde el año 2008 y eso
no es todo entre eso a ver también está
haber logrado que Francia esté teniendo
la recuperación poscovit más rápida de
todas las grandes economías de Europa de
hecho tal y como podéis ver en este
gráfico era la única gran economía que a
finales del 2021 ya había recuperado su
nivel prepandemia Pero vale exactamente
qué es lo que ha hecho
pues veréis entre sus primeras medidas
tras ser investido presidente en 2017
estuvo abolir el impuesto de patrimonio
y entre Esos grandes logros se suele
destacar la reducción de 8 puntos en el
impuesto de sociedades que era uno de
los más altos del mundo y también la
reforma laboral que facilitó la
contratación y el despido Quizás por
ello nos resulta extraño que según las
encuestas casi ocho de cada 10
directivos de empresas francesas hayan
votado precisamente por Emanuel macron
pero un momento no se equivoquéis en
cualquier caso hablamos de cambios
tímidos al menos mucho más tímidos de
los que realmente necesita la economía
gala Pero eso sí de momento han
funcionado Y esa es precisamente la
línea de trabajo que ahora se ha
comprometido a seguir entre sus promesas
está reducir los impuestos sobre la
producción para empresas y autónomos en
otros siete mil millones de euros
tampoco gran cosa recortar el impuesto
de sucesiones y alcanzar un déficit del
3% del pib para el año 2027 es decir en
otras palabras ajustes y discretos y
cinco años más gastando a lo loco porque
amigos Más allá de las palabras si hay
algo que a este presidente le gusta
hacer es gastar a este presidente y a la
mayoría de los políticos franceses
[Música]
tan solo desde que dio comienzo la
Guerra de Ucrania el gobierno francés se
ha gastado 22.000 millones de euros en
compensar a los consumidores y las
empresas por las subidas del gas la
electricidad o la gasolina todo a golpe
de dinero público y de hecho las
estimaciones apuntan a que las promesas
de macron Lejos de contener la
hemorragia fiscal añadirían 44 mil
millones de euros anuales más al déficit
del gobierno francés si es que se cumple
sus promesas Claro está sea como sea lo
que sí se espera de este presidente en
este segundo mandato es un rol
internacional mucho pero que mucho más
agresivo amigos macron quiere lograr que
para irse ponga los mandos de Bruselas y
sin ir más lejos en los últimos meses ya
hemos visto como ha querido jugar un
papel muy pero que muy relevante en la
crisis de Ucrania aunque no le haya
salido particularmente bien cómo iba a
pensar El Bueno de Manuel que no sería
capaz de hacer entrar en razón habla de
mil Putin cosas que pasan El caso es que
ahora se da por hecho que el gobierno
francés apoyará que Europa establezca un
embargo petrolero sobre Rusia pero
sabéis que justo la crisis de Ucrania
nos ha enseñado una de las partes más
volátiles y violetas de este personaje
Esta es quizás la peor cara del
presidente de Francia el Eterno
oportunismo de París atentos
[Música]
la cara más oportunista del presidente
galo
sobre todo Y ante todo queridos amigos
amigas ha sido un tipo con suerte y con
la suficiente agilidad para mover sus
naves de rumbo cuando el viento soplaba
en una dirección distinta a la suya el
último ejemplo lo tuvimos precisamente
con la invasión rusa de Ucrania o mejor
dicho Durante los prolegómenos de la
invasión tal y como ellos contamos en el
boletín de patrón y también aquí en
visualpolitik en un pasado vídeo macron
quiso aprovechar la tensión en la
frontera ucraniana para poner distancia
con Washington reclamar una postura
europea propia a negociar con Putin y
vengarse por la frente sufrida con aucus
cuando el gobierno australiano canceló
un contrato multimillonario de
submarinos con la industria militar
francesa para pactar otro con Estados
Unidos y el Reino Unido Y eso eso no fue
lo peor lo peor es que París se enteró
prácticamente por la prensa Ay qué poco
queda de la histórica influencia de
Francia
[Música]
El caso es que en ese momento el
presidente francés dijo cosas como esta
los europeos deben dejar de ser ingenuos
tenemos que responder y demostrar que
tenemos la fuerza y la capacidad para
defendernos en Manuel macrón Así que
cuando las cosas en Ucrania se pusieron
Al rojo vivo macron vio la oportunidad
perfecta para aceptarle una patada al
gobierno de Estados Unidos por eso en el
mismísimo parlamento europeo dijo
exactamente esto es bueno que los
europeos y los Estados Unidos se
coordinen pero es necesario que los
europeos lleven a cabo su propio diálogo
Emmanuel macron presidente de Francia
ante el parlamento europeo ni postura
común y reforzar la otan ni nada por el
estilo la Unión Europea tenía que ir por
libre para negociar con Putin Claro que
no convenció prácticamente a nadie
mientras París hacía un llamamiento a la
unidad europea Varsovia tallín riga
billions bragas todo el colmopenaga
bratislava prácticamente todas las
capitales comenzaron a mirar Washington
y a la otan era desde luego la mejor
protección posible de hecho la única
posible y para colmo luego se produjo la
invasión ella estaba Claro que la
respuesta militar era la única viable y
tangana por goleada Así que el plan de
macron se fue a hacer puñetas
[Música]
Y sabéis qué ocurrió que entonces el
presidente de un giro de 180 grados un
giro que en cierta forma también ha
protagonizado durante la campaña de la
segunda vuelta cuando ha hecho suyas
algunas posiciones de la izquierda como
por ejemplo ralentizar el incremento de
la edad de jubilación o volcarse con los
verdes Exactamente lo contrario de lo
que indica su propio diagnóstico
económico
macron diluye la reforma clave de las
pensiones en un intento de cortejar a la
izquierda evidentemente el poder es el
poder y Francia es Francia tampoco vamos
a culparle de ello y pedir peras al olmo
el problema amigos es que estas
cuestiones reflejan las grandes
carencias del presidente galo macron ha
contribuido a mejorar Francia Sí pero no
ha protagonizado el cambio radical que
prometió ni desde luego parecen
disposición de hacerlo ahora la victoria
de macron significa continuidad en la
política económica y también en la
política exterior y eso sí y aquí me
vais a permitir mojarme personalmente
aunque los resultados hasta ahora han
sido más bien pobres parece Claro que
era con diferencia la mejor opción y no
solo estoy hablando de Marin le pen lo
cierto Es que casi que podríamos decir
que la política de Francia está a la
deriva
[Música]
política de extremos
atentos a estas declaraciones en cuanto
a la guerra ruso creen en haya terminado
y se haya resuelto con un tratado de paz
pedir El apuesta en marcha de un
acercamiento estratégico entre la otan y
Rusia que ves en interés de Francia y
Europa así como de Estados Unidos Marín
le pen unas declaraciones que se
entienden mejor cuando tenemos en cuenta
este otro compromiso
sacar a Francia del mando Aliado de la
otan sigan a las presidenciales amigos a
Francia como todo una superpotencia
mundial que tiene que ir por libre una
superpotencia que tiene que reclamar su
sitio en el mundo y para ello no ve nada
mejor que mandar al [ __ ] a la otan y
en cierto modo también a la Unión
Europea para impulsar así políticas
proteccionistas al acercarse a Moscú y
hacer malabares económicos porque le
prometió grandes bajadas de impuestos Sí
pero también grandes incrementos del
gasto Y qué queréis que os diga eso no
suele ser una buena combinación huele
más a populismo que a cualquier otra
cosa como cuando dice querer luchar
contra la inflación castigando el
comercio internacional y bajando el IVA
lo que impulsaría aún más la demanda de
las familias y con ella los precios y
vuelta a empezar pero bueno ya sabemos
que el papel lo aguanta todo para que
sois una idea sea cuantificado que las
promesas del pen supondrían un déficit
adicional de 150.000 millones de dólares
por año para alcanzar un agujero total
de 266 mil millones de dólares anuales
un agujero descomunal ya sabéis hacer
Irlanda Francia o mejor dicho a la deuda
francesa
[Música]
entre sus propuestas también
encontrábamos cosas como restablecer el
impuesto sobre el patrimonio
nacionalizar la red de autopistas bajar
la edad de jubilación a 60 años o pagar
a las familias hasta 100.000 euros a
cambio de que tuvieran al menos tres
hijos todo por supuesto a golpe de
chequera pública ahí el cambio amigos
durante el siglo XVIII Francia le dio al
mundo los conceptos de izquierda y
derecha Pues bien Ahora este país está
liderando también una nueva transición
de bandos políticos que el analista
richmann califica como nacionalistas
contra internacionalistas entre quienes
temen la globalización y quienes la
abrazan como una oportunidad aquí Marín
le pen es muy pero que muy clara no hay
más izquierda ni derecha la verdadera
división es entre Los Patriotas y los
globalistas Marín le pen Claro que eso
en cierto modo es limitar y simplificar
mucho el espectro político sea como sea
a pesar del resultado la extrema derecha
del LP ni compañía está hoy más fuerte
que nunca y de hecho estuvo por delante
entre los jóvenes y la clase trabajadora
el nacionalismo el euro escepticismo y
el rechazo de inmigración cada vez gana
más adeptos
[Música]
y por la izquierda a tres cuartas partes
de lo mismo porque que el líder del
bloque de izquierda sea un candidato tan
radical como melenchon tampoco inspira
mucha confianza amigos la sociedad
francesa parece cada vez más dividida y
polarizada Y si las cosas siguen yendo
de mal empleo en Francia puede que en
poco tiempo el resultado de las
elecciones sea muy pero que muy
diferente de hecho en la primera vuelta
el histórico central del partido
socialista francés se quedó con el 2% de
los votos y el centro derecha ni
siquiera alcanzó un raquítico 5%. el
espectro político se repartió entre el
centro de macron y los dos extremos el
mayor desafío de macron será crear una
sensación de cohesión en un país
extremadamente fragmentado garabarma con
seguro europeo de relaciones exteriores
Pero al menos por ahora hay cinco años
de continuidad
esto es precisamente por lo que la
reelección del presidente galo ha sido
también recibida entre los grandes
líderes internacionales desde vaivén
hasta el propio celenski pasando por
bonderley felicidades a Manuel macron
por su reelección Francia es nuestro
Aliado más antiguo y un socio clave para
abordar los desafíos globales espero con
interés nuestra estrecha cooperación
continua Incluso en el apoyo Ucrania la
defensa de la democracia y la lucha
contra el cambio climático Joe biden sea
como sea ahora se abre una nueva batalla
lo que se conoce como la tercera vuelta
Macro necesita ganar las elecciones a la
asamblea nacional de junio para poder
gobernar A su antojo Y qué queréis que
os diga visto lo visto esperemos que lo
consiga macron no está siendo un
presidente revolucionario vale Pero al
menos Ha logrado girar algo el oxido
timón de la política francesa sí puede
que no sea suficiente pero algo es algo
y en las alternativas no parece que haya
más que viajas recetas que recuerdan más
a los viejos mensajes populistas de
América Latina que a los países más
prósperos claro que Francia necesita
tantos cambios economía pensiones de
seguridad
en cualquier caso como curiosidad
resulta sorprendente los resultados de
las elecciones en los territorios
franceses de ultramar han sido
completamente distintos a los de la
metrópoli en la Francia más alejada de
París Marín le pena ha tenido unos
resultados particularmente buenos de
hecho ha ganado lugares como reunión
Guadalupe La guayana o Martinica entre
otros en algunos además por una
diferencia enorme qué ocurre con la
Francia de ultramar Por qué Parece tan
distante a la metrópolis pues queridos
amigos amigas de todo y hablaremos en un
próximo vídeo aquí en visualpolitik Así
que no olvidéis suscribiros al Canal si
es que aún no lo habéis hecho y ahora
turno para ti qué piensas de los
resultados de las elecciones francesas
qué opinión tienes de Manuel macron que
es que Francia logrará de una vez por
todas remontar el vuelo déjanos por aquí
abajo tus comentarios y ya sabes si este
vídeo te resultó interesante No olvides
darle al botón de like una vez más
Muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]